this conversation is with eric weiss the
ceo of the bitcoin investment group i
really enjoyed my conversation with eric
and we go over everything from what
bitcoin is doing in this high inflation
environment to how family offices and
sophisticated investors are viewing it
as part of their portfolio these
episodes are brought to you by ftxus go
click on the link in the description to
learn more let's get into this episode
with eric i hope you guys learned just
as much as i did all right we've got
eric with us eric how are you i'm good
man how you doing i'm pumped uh you have
a nice shirt on but you do not have on a
suit and tie to defeat the bear market i
know i'm impressed man i i've been i've
been beating you up a long time to like
wear a suit and tie and not a black
hoodie and then i show up underneath
uh let's talk inflation first which i
think is the backdrop for the entire
investment world right now uh the fed
seems to be in control they say they're
going to destroy demand inflation
numbers today 9.1 percent
what is your read as to how to think
about the actual inflation people are
experiencing do you believe the 9.1
percent number or do you think there's a
different way to think about it
i think uh you know inflation is a
vector it's not just one static number
to say this is the inflation rate and i
think it's pretty well documented that
inflation in the areas that matter most
whether you're talking about prices at
the pump food prices the things that are
affecting real everyday people are
dramatically higher than the 9.1 percent
but even if you go with the broken
metrics of 9.1 percent we're talking
about the highest inflation in 40 years
this is dramatic and if you look at
inflation in other countries it's
considerably worse so globally we've got
a massive problem and nobody is immune
to it
obviously it it hits you know people
living paycheck to paycheck the hardest
because they don't own assets that
inflate you know with this inflation um
yeah it's a really vicious thing
everybody's in the same boat
many investors including myself uh kept
talking about bitcoin as an inflation
hedge i think now there is kind of a
nuanced view of that which is well maybe
it's not an inflation hedge in the sense
of inflation goes up and bitcoin goes up
uh to combat that but maybe it's
actually a hedge on the loose monetary
policy so if the fed says they're going
to titan bitcoin has come down because
people anticipate risk assets to come
down how do you think about whether it's
an inflation hedge or it's a loose
monetary policy i've read some stuff on
that as well and i you know the
correlation to the monetary policy is
pretty strong and so right now
that's looking like a pretty viable
perspective that said i think that
bitcoin ultimately is an inflation hedge
and that what we're dealing with are
some unique circumstances where
obviously there's very
thin float in bitcoin from a trading
volume point of view relative to other
assets so it's not manipulated in a
negative way but when you get things
like we have now where there's a
correlation to equities with bitcoin
which i think will ultimately break
because bitcoin is not in equity um but
right now it is heavily correlated and
that correlation is being enforced by
big macro hedge funds who are using
bitcoin to hedge their equity exposure
particularly to
nasdaq and big tech equity so if a big
macro hedge fund has a billion dollars
of big tech exposure and they want to
hedge that because the correlation you
know with bitcoin to tech is kind of
four to one like almost a four beta so
if you had a billion dollars of exposure
you could short 250 million dollars of
bitcoin and be equally hedged so if
stocks go down one percent bitcoin you
know is gonna go down four percent and
vice versa so i think that's reinforcing
this correlation which is kind of
hurting us right now that'll ultimately
break and i also think we get that kind
of technology adoption volatility
i think back to amazon you know ever
since amazon was a public company it has
lost 80 percent of its market cap uh six
times and one time more than 90 percent
so this is kind of expected and it's
hard to be an inflation hedge when you
have that degree of volatility but
ultimately as the asset matures i think
it's going to prove to be an inflation
edge when you think of the fed and
they're kind of talk track right now
obviously they are talking about
destroying demand uh which i always
remind folks just me they're going to
punish you until you stop buying things
and we have seen risk assets go down
because people are selling them because
they're listening to the fed but
inflation's still at 9.1 percent and
it's actually accelerating
what are they gonna have to do like can
the fed actually get inflation under
control or
no matter what they do it's not going to
come down uh and so maybe they're going
to have to pivot before inflation
actually comes down
i don't think they're going to have to
pivot before inflation comes down i
think that the fed can be pretty
effective by raising rates it has a
pretty dramatic effect
maybe the most obvious place to see it
is in housing we're already seeing
more housing deals break that are in
contract than we've seen in a really
long time and just to follow that
through one step it's
as interest rates go up and those
mortgage rates that were two and a half
three and a half percent are now six
percent mortgage rate people are
breaking those deals
prices of houses are being revised
downward um so i think we're starting to
see that and we're going to see it
across the board even more um demand is
going to decrease and i think there's
signs that it already is yeah when you
look at core inflation versus kind of
cpi inflation that includes energy and
food uh is there a reason to look at
core inflation like i know the fed likes
to point at it because it's going down
right now so that's their signal of
saying oh look inflation is going to get
under control how do you look at those
two numbers and do you put more weight
on either one of them no i just think of
i try to think of it across the entire
spectrum of assets and services and
there's what numbers say on reports docs
news reports etc and there's what every
individual feels and the truth of the
matter is i think most people only care
what their personal exposure to
inflation is how is this affecting me
and everyone goes to restaurants
everyone drives a car not everyone sends
it to those prices there are people with
ton of money who are like i don't give a
[ __ ] if the entree is 50 or 75 at the
restaurant i eat but there are a lot of
people who do care about all those
things but those people even the really
affluent people they do care about
whether or not their purchasing power uh
is impacting their ability to purchase a
house you know and all of a sudden even
that wealthy person is thinking of
buying you know this 15 million dollar
house and is going to put you know 13
million of that you know in debt on
mortgage they care that that interest
rate is six percent and not three
percent and so if it impacts everyone i
just look at it through my personal
vantage point to try to assess what the
real impact is and it's dramatic i mean
i i feel it yeah i um uh continue to
be blown away by the cost of food food
to me is the big one right um you know
gas obviously is high but i think that
they've got a stronger argument as to
it's not just monetary policy that's
driving that there's supply chains
there's geopolitical conflict all that
uh food uh while yes there is a little
bit that can be attributed to some of
the geopolitical conflict and breaking
the supply chains yeah it feels like
that is very much uh more tied to uh um
kind of the the monster policy and just
12 percent increase food at home massive
i mean
i had dinner with a buddy of mine uh
this past week uh here in miami and he
runs business uh here he's got a couple
hundred employees and he was telling me
true story about a woman that works for
him she makes 60 70 000 a year kind of
range and she came to him and she asked
for a raise and never came to him worked
for him for many years never came and
asked for a raise and uh he said you
know sure tell me why and she said you
know
i can't afford the gas and the grocery
she said i've been going the grocery
store you know blah blah blah so
frequently it's oe i get the same thing
every time and it's always between you
know like 200 and 220 dollars and now
it's you know closer to 300 and she
can't make it on what she's gotten it's
like it really hits you know when you
hear it at that level this is not just
some fictitious numbers that you're
hearing spouted on cnbc this is really
impacting everyone yeah it's pretty
incredible you talk to a lot of family
offices uh and manage capital on their
behalf what are they talking about right
now in terms of bitcoin and its
relationship to inflation
yeah so they're generally speaking and
you can't generalize because every
family office and every family has kind
of a different perspective on on their
investments but generally speaking
they're in the stay rich game not the
get rich game you're talking about
families that have had money for
generations in a lot of cases
and
they're scared of inflation too yeah
they own assets that are inflating as
well but this is really scary stuff for
anybody and the one thing they know is
if they sit in us dollar cash even
though
dollars kick and ass against every other
currency sure they'll go to europe this
summer and they're happy that there's
parity you know and
europe feels cheap but they know that
their dollars are melting away and that
that probably isn't going to reverse
course anytime soon so they're looking
for ways to hedge that inflation and
bitcoin is something that comes up it
you know initially it was something they
dismissed
and then as as you know we used to see
each other on that circuit back in the
day right and uh when you had that great
line just get off zero that was it that
was it i think it's still relevant today
unfortunately but really that that's the
key but
so they were kicking tires back then
they just wanted information they had a
son or daughter or grandchild that was
telling them about this bitcoin stuff
and they dismissed them and kind of
pushed it off and now this bitcoin thing
is a bug in the bottom right constant of
their cnbc screen its front page of
their wall street journal their new york
times everything so now they're coming
and saying hey
what's going on here is this the digital
gold what am i missing why is everyone
talking about this and really they want
to dip a toe and then once they cross
that threshold of saying okay i want to
dip a toe i feel like i should have some
exposure to this
um then it's a matter of evaluating the
different ways that they could have that
exposure and that's where it gets pretty
unique because
this group of investors they want this
to feel like other investments they've
made they just want it to be comfortable
right um so
do they go
you know how do they buy bitcoin right
do they
self-custody that's not something that's
really palatable for this 75 year old
matriarch or patriarch of this family
office who's like you know gonna have to
worry about they're
just not appealing to them do they go to
a new exchange like a coinbase or
something that they've heard about read
about ipo public company yeah that's
great except
two weeks ago it was a hundred billion
dollar market cap and now it's 10
billion dollar market cap and is it
going to be here tomorrow
not interested in that for the most part
either so
you know gbtc yeah that's an option why
is it at a 30 discount there's no etf or
etp out there which would be a nice kind
of first order derivative um so really
they want a way to own bitcoin and
that's why i started
my fund bitcoin investment group which
we just charge one percent and we try to
give them the best of all worlds which
is we custody at fidelity digital assets
which is a name that they're comfortable
with um it's a buy and hold strategy
where we
they give a million dollars we buy a
million dollars a bitcoin we maintain
separate tax accounting for them so
they're not impacted by anybody else's
movements in the fund and then the
really cool thing about it which was
important to me
was
if and when they decide they want out
and they want to redeem they have a
choice we can sell the bitcoin and send
them us dollars or they can have the
bitcoin sent to you know their wallet
which is pretty cool so they can
actually take possession of it and why
are they so injured is it because
inflation is it because uh they feel
like there's asymmetry and it's just uh
you know uh kind of on top of and kind
of higher leverage exposure to like risk
asset like what is driving their
interest other than just oh i hear the
people talking about it over the last
year it's been inflation that's been a
key it's it was the narrative that
bitcoin is a digital gold is i think the
one that resonated the most because
i think when especially when you're when
you've got that generational gap
having
a close simile to something that you
know they're familiar with makes it easy
to understand so they understand the
challenges of gold they understand that
that gold bar is really difficult to
move around and their kids aren't
interested in it so they know that
there's a gap there right and you talk
about bitcoin in the context of digital
gold and you point out all the things
that make you know bitcoin better than
gold they start to understand it they
may there may be a leap of faith there
and accepting that this is going to be a
thing but then you start talking about
kind of how your kid was really
comfortable buying that skin for ten
dollars in the video game that had no
value don't you think
that his generation or her generation is
going to be comfortable owning this
digital asset the same way and then you
can see the wheels start to churn in the
clicks from and they say okay let's take
a shot let's do something here and how
much are they putting in on the
portfolio basis this like one to two
percent is this let's get to ten percent
it's still it's still
low single digits we're not seeing i'm
not seeing
uh anybody say yeah let's let's pile in
i want 40 50 percent you know of my
money in this but what i am seeing this
time around that's really different than
past bear markets and i think this is
super encouraging past
bohr markets the feedback we got is
kind of a venture mentality like oh [ __ ]
did we blow our money on this is it all
gone like we took a shot oh well kind of
thing now it's very much not that now
the calls that i'm getting from existing
clients is hey is it time to buy more at
what price do you think we buy more um
and people have like this number in mind
that they want to hit whether it's 100
bitcoin or whatever it is they've got
some number in their head and
this you know dip as we say in our world
which is not a dip but this downturn is
an opportunity for them to you know
average price average down and hit the
numbers they're looking to hit and
when we get into these bear markets do
you see difference in new clients like
in in the sense of the interest are they
scared because the price went down 70
are they excited if they haven't don't
already have exposure oh now you know i
feel like i didn't miss it i can go and
buy more like what are you hearing it
runs the gamut the challenge that
bitcoin has relative to a stock or a
piece of real estate or something else
is when the price goes down we don't
have a stream of cash flows to say hey
this is cheap right it's not trading at
a multiple of earnings or a discounted
cash flow we don't have those metrics
with bitcoin so people can get scared
and just be like oh [ __ ] the price is
down you know momentum is the key thing
here it's just gonna go further down so
we see that we see the gamut people
who've done the research spent the time
if they put in a hundred or a thousand
hours researching this they have
conviction and they're like this is a
buying opportunity i'd like to buy more
you know what and then they you know
maybe get a little technical analysis
and they say how far do you think we can
go down on this cycle you know where
should we buy and they try to optimize
that we've seen issues with stable coins
uh with various lending outlets both in
the decentralized and centralized world
uh over the last you know six to eight
months how much of that uh kind of um uh
news and developments have either helped
bitcoin or hurt bitcoin and kind of
people's adoption or are these family
offices paying attention to that stuff
uh and kind of what is the impact of it
yeah
as you all know don't end don't
underestimate
the intellect and
access to information that family
offices have these are these are people
with means who care about things who pay
attention to everything right they will
continue to impress you with what they
know um
but generally speaking
uh what i'm seeing is
the media is doing us a disservice this
this blanket term of crypto is a
tremendous disservice right because it
paints everything with the same brush
and even as we talk about kind of you
know the firms that you alluded to that
have struggled over the you know past
handful of months
with liquidity issues even within that
specific genre i think we're not parsing
it enough to see where the problems are
and where they are the truth is
in those areas that had problems it was
the centralized players right like um
celsius bla-fi these guys these are
centralized finance not decentralized
finance the truly decentralized finance
um where it's kind of smart contract
based no hey we'll make a loan without
collateral kind of decision making no
back office handshake kind of stuff
they fared much better than centralized
finance players do but this general
painting of this big brush of crypto
with luna and all this other crap and
the stable coin problems bitcoin gets
lumped into that discussion and i think
that as we kind of this asset class
evolves we'll get more definition of
more things and bitcoin bitcoin really
is not crypto in my opinion it's its own
thing totally separate different value
proposition going after a much larger
addressable market and has a
much more certain future based on a lot
of what's played out over the last
couple weeks even a couple of months uh
it feels like uh disclosure requirements
will significantly increase uh there
will likely be more regulation more
regulatory clarity um i'm assuming that
that is a big tailwind for institutions
and family offices uh and the kind of
their interest in bitcoin do you agree
or disagree with completely agree yeah
and is there something specific that
they're looking for like when they they
say regulatory clarity like
we have the sec chairman on national
television saying bitcoin is not a
security you know there's data points
but is there something that they're like
okay when we get x
then um interested etf approval or
something else like what are they
waiting for i think it's more
concrete regulation than etf approval
will help
um but generally speaking i think to to
to summarize kind of their perspective
it's kind of like headline risk right um
no one wants to make
a ton of money
uh in the financial world if it comes
with headline risk you
insider traded you engaged in something
that you know was a security before it
was recognized as security they don't
want the black eye that's going to come
with it it's like well if you buy you
know
if you buy a lot of bitcoin and scream
about it and the price goes up you know
is someone going to come after you in
some form manipulation you know play or
something so they just want regulatory
clarity and then when the institutions
have that regulatory clarity i think
there'll be much more
comfort in them allocating larger chunks
of capital to it they want to come in
now and they understand like hey the
price is low because these things aren't
in place so there's a risk reward
profile for dipping that toe now and
getting smart on it so that when there
is some clarity and less ambiguity they
can just flick a switch and come in much
bigger way yeah um
many of these wealthy families own
businesses
or are large shareholders and other
businesses is there a thought process
that once they personally start to
allocate that will leak into either the
businesses they own or that there are
shareholders of
i think so i i think what's going to
happen that's kind of key for bitcoin is
kind of what happens to gold where
there's no price sensitivity to gold if
you're at a investment bank or asset
management firm uh it's an allocation
right so your investment manager will
sit down with you and they'll say well
you've got two million dollars with us
and we're you know we should allocate
you know 10 of that to gold we'll put
200 000 into gold there's no discussion
of what the price per ounce of gold is
so when bitcoin kind of gets to that
threshold i think we'll see that same
thing and it'll be like okay it'll be an
allocation it'll be we should put x
percent of this money into bitcoin not
hey what price per bitcoin are we
trading at in dollars yeah and i guess
as you look around the world is there a
difference between like u.s based uh
investors and maybe people in developing
nations or in other parts of the world
of their interest level
at the family office level
um well yeah there is i mean i talked to
some some folks in south america
and here in the states you can you can
be fooled into thinking that inflation
is not as pernicious as you may think
right because the dollar has fared
better than every other currency
however
uh you know you talk to uh you talk to a
family office in argentina or venezuela
and they really get it they're they're
looking for bitcoin they don't give a
rat's ass about the volatility because
they're looking at 100 percent inflation
here in their currency and they're just
looking to get it into assets that are
going to fare better yeah and i guess a
huge piece of uh family offices
obviously they do a lot of investing but
also uh because they own businesses uh
they build companies do you see any of
them saying hey you know what maybe i
want to allocate to bitcoin maybe i
don't but like maybe we should go build
services or companies around the bitcoin
network the payment rails uh
infrastructure anything like that i have
not seen that yet i would love to see it
but i haven't seen it yet yeah it's
interesting uh from the perspective of
i've seen more and more family offices
start to look for venture exposure in
the bitcoin ecosystem um but i haven't
yet seen those family offices hey well
we've built you know 10 other businesses
right maybe we should go build in this
space maybe mike ricardo salinas maybe
you know a little bit falls into that
camp but generally mining yeah you bring
a mining um
yeah i haven't i haven't seen that yet
um they're pretty familiar with on the
venture side of things they are
interested in in venture type stuff but
they're really viewing bitcoin generally
speaking as a digital gold which
personally i think is the most healthy
narrative for bitcoin yeah uh why do you
think it's the most healthy one
it's relatable
it's true the benefits of bitcoin
relative to gold are dramatic anybody
can understand them and selfishly as a
huge proponent of bitcoin i think if you
can get to a place where bitcoin starts
to rival gold at that you know even half
of gold even 5 trillion dollar level 250
000
per bitcoin i think everything else that
all the maxies dream about starts to
fall into place and all of those battles
are a lot easier at 250 000 to 500 000
and if history is going to repeat itself
every time
a digital successor has you know
replaced an analog predecessor that
digital successor has dwarfed that
analog predecessor by a tremendous
amount of magnitudes yeah yeah what are
you hearing uh in the conversation
around bitcoin obviously there's the
mainstream conversation you see cnbc
bloomberg many of the mainstream outlets
talking about it now uh but then there's
also like kind of bitcoin twitter and it
feels like there's a ton of infighting
right now and most of that i'm assuming
is because of the bear market although
it's hard to kind of pinpoint one thing
just prices go down people are bored and
yell and scream at each other but
do most of these investors or family
offices are they on twitter do they pay
attention to that stuff are they
completely immune to it i think they're
fairly immune to it uh i don't have too
many of my clients that follow me on
twitter um
so
i don't have too many people that follow
me on twitter but um
but no i think i think they're really
immune to it we're in our own little
world and i think it's not just boredom
that's brought out some of this vitriol
it's that people are all in and they're
committed and
when you're all in and it goes down you
know
50 or something um that causes personal
anxiety and twitter is an outlet for
emotions and we see a lot of that i
personally i think
um
you know some of the toxic stuff is is
really counterproductive to bitcoin
because it does get picked up by media
it does get put into news articles and
if we want bitcoin to spread the way we
all want it to spread it needs to be
approachable and welcoming and
it's really it's always been really
ironic to me that you know some hardcore
bitcoiners will want to dictate how
these pro-freedom people want to dictate
how different people use bitcoin you
know well they're not all in you know
like elon musk only bought a billion and
a half dollars worth of bitcoin we hate
him it's like no dude we love him thank
you elon you know like that's great i i
uh uh whenever i hear the term real
bitcoiner and you know look i've
probably used it in the past as well
right just in conversation whatever but
uh when you hear that term it's almost
this like uh somebody who holds you know
one bitcoin and then holds a bunch of
other assets and it's a small percentage
are they a bitcoiner and there's a lot
of folks who would say no right right
right right okay um totally contrary to
the get off zero right which is like
come on just get get involved once you
start paying attention to it you'll go
up the learning curve and i also think
um and i've talked about this before on
the show but uh there is a skill in
being able to disagree with someone
without uh offending them right it's
almost like a um uh uh if you think like
a statesman right which by the way is
like hilarious for anyone on twitter to
be talking about statesmanship right
because for the most part everyone has
had a bad day and said something stupid
or bombastic or whatever but there is
this like statesmanship uh where it
takes intelligence it takes maturity it
takes uh emotional control it takes
patience right all these things that
like every human is like you know i got
to improve at those things
but if you can be somewhat of a
statesman and disagree with somebody and
have the patience what ends up happening
i think is your credibility goes through
the roof yeah and they and they just
start to realize like oh this isn't like
an emotional lashing out or anything
like that this is like somebody who
understands this is trying to help me
understand it and uh maybe somebody i
should be listening to or paying more
attention to yeah in addition to that i
think i agree with you completely but in
addition to that i think our society has
become so polarized on topics um you
know think political right it's like one
person says black the other person says
white just reflexively right so
bitcoin is really unique in the sense
that uh its appeal is truly bipartisan
right i think the value proposition to
the constituency that the left claims to
represent is even stronger than the
value proposition bitcoin has to the
kind of affluent investment right this
banking the unbanked and narrowing the
wealth gap is a truly better value
proposition for bitcoin than the latter
a la jack dorsey is interested in it
right and so i think and just look at
the bill right cynthia lumus and
gillibrand i mean
how many topics have you seen in the
last you know year that have bipartisan
support in the united states government
not a lot
so i think that we're really missing an
opportunity not to seize on that and
leverage that and be something that's
appealing to everyone in whatever degree
or application it's applicable to them
and be the big tent that welcomes
everybody because that's really you know
to my understanding the ethos of bitcoin
right um so i think we're missing an
opportunity and i think the infighting
and toxicity kind of takes us away from
that yeah one development uh that's
actually been pretty surprising to me is
i saw recently i don't know if it was
proposal or actually got approved uh and
i believe it came from maybe a
government ethics board or kind of
community uh was they don't want uh
politicians who hold bitcoin talking
about bitcoin
i think it was
they don't want politicians who
hold even like a hundred dollars worth
of bitcoin
being involved in
writing
some of the legislation related to it
right so according to bloomberg law uh
it will give them credit and say that
they got it right u.s officials holding
cryptocurrencies and stable coins
directly as personal investments will
generally be barred from advising
president joe biden how to oversee the
digital currency government's ethics
chief said which
okay
does that now mean if you hold us
dollars you should have no say in what
happens from a fiscal policy standpoint
it sounds ridiculous but from what i
remember it doesn't actually pertain to
legislators so it wouldn't pertain to
like
senators or congress people i don't
think got it so it would basically be uh
other federal workers right
it sounds completely ridiculous to me
i wonder if that's because uh
[Music]
they don't have oversight over the
senators and congressmen
it got even easier actually the actual
whoever wrote
that legislation
like the level of ignorance was painful
because they even specifically said
stable coins like you can't own stable
coins and they talked about how the
legislation might benefit like the
holders of this like it may stay at one
dollar
if it's pegged at a dollar and you
really benefit it might go all the way
up to a dollar like it just makes no
sense in the coin desk article they
wrote uh direct quote the directive will
likely have a significant impact on some
white house staffers who have been open
about their crypto investments like tim
wu a technology advisor to the biden
administration who holds millions of
dollars in bitcoin wu has already
voluntarily recruit recused himself from
working on crypto policy end quote and
so uh
it kind of feels like if you have a
technology advice you want them to
advise you on the technology yeah by
definition we're
saying that the people who are most
informed on the topic are not allowed to
weigh in
yeah and i guess you know it's a it's a
weird thing where uh if everyone should
open hey this is my bias this is my
disclosure right which i think is what
historically they try to get at uh
that's probably good i think most people
they like the disclosures they like
knowing that information well you get
balance right if you if you take out all
the people of one constituency from the
discussion then you're swaying yes to
discussion it uh it always goes back to
um mainstream media right if uh if they
hold uh bitcoin and they write an
article first of all most of them are
barred from holding any investment so
they don't even
hold it but if they did they have to
disclose hey i hold bitcoin uh but every
single article that you'll read about uh
the us dollar there's no disclosures
right
yeah and uh i i get it right it's the
native currency of the economy it's
legal tender all this stuff uh but there
is a little aspect here of but the sub
point how are we gonna treat it yeah but
the sub point there is there's
tremendous benefit to not being a
security right you can't
a senator or congress person can
advocate for a security
on senate floor but you could advocate
for property and bitcoin being property
is more analogous to the us dollar as
you say than it is a stock or a company
or a bond yeah it um uh it definitely
and another piece too that i think is
interesting is like in the united states
uh almost every single state not every
state but most states have some sort of
property tax right for real estate and
things like that uh which means even if
you buy in cash there's still a tax and
there's plenty of people who i think
would be you know on the more
libertarian or extreme uh end of the
spectrum they'd be like oh we shouldn't
even have that but those are the rules
people want to follow the rules um
bitcoin as property doesn't have a
property tax in the sense of every year
you owe x percent uh and
that is like a unique thing where you
have this digital property but there is
no property tax now there's capital
gains tax if you sell and and whatever
um but there's not necessarily federal
there's not federal property tax on your
home
right that would be a state state level
right and then i think a lot of people
are also unaware that gold has its own
tax rate right what what is do you know
the tax rate yeah it's 28
28 for buying and selling gold
collective collectible tax yeah
it's uh it's it's pretty incredible you
start to have 40 percent higher than cap
cans yeah yeah well and it's also uh
when you start to look at um
the incentives that are in place
right uh taxation uh definitely has a
huge ability to uh incentivize people or
punish people depending on what they're
doing uh which i think to your point the
security aspect is not taxes but it
still has an ability to incentivize
certain behavior versus other behavior
hence everybody move into our state man
that is uh that is true today we looked
at the top
states for business there's a cnbc poll
florida was not even in the top ten it
was number 11. great that's awesome
[Laughter]
don't come
especially don't come from uh california
or new york
well now we have citadel that it's gonna
move to uh move to
miami uh uh i was talking to a guy this
morning and he was like yes i was trying
to calculate you know how many employees
what's the average pay he was like i
think that uh you know some places in
the world like miami may not uh be
experiencing the same letdown in real
estate prices or other things because
there's literally an influx of people
with high income that are willing to
spend money and so restaurants benefit
real estate benefits all these pieces of
an economy
and it's just the dynamic of you have
new people showing up with more money
than the people who are already there
generally speaking i think that
the united states is going to start to
focus more and more on state level
policies as opposed to federal policies
and people to the extent that they're
mobile and have the freedom to choose
are going to choose to live in states
that
are more emblematic of their personal
beliefs and i think as a
red tax friendly state with the only
tropical climate in the continental u.s
and a great international airport and
kind of the hub to the caribbean and
south and latin america i think miami is
going to thrive for the next decade
i uh that's a big part of the thesis as
to why i live here
i'm glad you do where can we send people
to find you on the internet or find out
more about the investment asset
management firm probably twitter um
i think my twitter is
eric
underscore big fund that's the big is
stands for bitcoin investment group so
amazing uh and i love orange pearl
michael saylor got him yeah
the the first time that we talked uh uh
you're like yeah i've been in bitcoin
since 2013. and uh it took a long time
but i've pretty much got all of my
friends now
pretty much do you have a friend left
that you haven't uh convinced
uh yeah i do
i do what is their biggest hang up like
what do they they still can't get across
uh
[Music]
uh they're they're a very successful
entrepreneur with their own fintech
company and they've got a ton of friends
in our space
and uh they live here in miami they've
killed it they've got a unicorn company
and
oh no he just doesn't want to touch it
doesn't believe in it doesn't give a
[ __ ] has his own thing and he's doing
great and i'm in no position to tell him
you have to do this so yeah
i love it uh last question for you is uh
eight sleep uh is one of our sponsors i
sleep on it every single night like a
baby um and i always tell you that when
i moved to south florida uh my life got
exponentially better i go outside i tend
to eat healthier i sleep better all this
stuff what is your daily routine now in
a bear market
it's pretty much the same as it is in a
bull market okay um personal daily
routine yeah
um
i don't really push my crap on other
people but about five or six years ago i
started doing uh transcendental
meditation so what is that
tm have you heard of tm no all right so
uh that was actually pitch me
it was actually happened here in miami i
was out
at a dinner with like six people and not
to name drop but one of the guys that
was at the dinner was dan loeb uh the
hedge fund manager who have a lot of
respect for intellectually i think he's
a real smart guy and he didn't strike me
as the kind of guy who would be
espousing meditation you know and it was
like the only topic he wanted to talk
about at dinner and what a great impact
it's had on him from investor clear head
or whatever so i started looking into it
and did a lot of research on it and
figured okay i'm gonna go you know learn
what the hell this is pay my little bit
of money to this company don't get don't
think it's not a company to give you a
mantra to sit there and quietly repeat
this word in your head for 20 minutes
twice a day and it's just been it's had
a very positive impact on me i used to
grind my teeth when i sleep and after a
week of doing this that completely
stopped i sleep infinitely better uh you
just sit and just say the same word over
and over and over again to yourself in
your head silently correct for twice a
day 20 minutes so
like is it the same word every time or
something same word every time uh you
pay this money to go get your mantra
which you know seems like it's special
for you but the truth is a lot of people
have similar marks it's a meaningless
word if your mantra was like
love right and you repeated the word
love over your head that has meaning
you'd think about maybe what love means
do you think about your wife think about
your daughter whatever um but they give
you like a meaningless word like a sound
like sharim or something and you repeat
that crap over in your head and it's
just
no pressure you just repeat it over and
kind of just like
kind of just like emptying the inbox of
your life you know and then when you're
done hopefully there's no unopened
messages and it's just kind of calmer
more tranquility the only thing that
it's been clinically proven to do is
reduce the cortisol levels in your brain
which is essentially stress
so it's that's been good for me i do
that um living in miami is nice i try to
go for you know either a bike ride along
the boardwalk or walk in the beach every
day for an hour and other than that just
try to eat healthy anytime there's like
particularly challenging times like bear
markets i just uh
i go with the clean up your life as much
as possible thing you know de-risk
d-rate yeah just you know just uh
not a lot of drinking you know zero
partying not a lot of excess just try to
kind of stay in your stay in your lane
focus so that when you come out of this
and better times are ahead you're not in
a worse position you're in a better
position i think that's great the the
meditation thing
i always fall asleep that's okay is that
okay yeah i've tried like i don't know
like two or three times not a lot of
times but every single time i'm like
sitting there sitting in there for five
minutes i fall asleep and i'm like oh
man i'm not good at this
did you try like the 20 minute versions
like the tm thing not the guidance i've
never uh uh i've never done anything
just i just sat there and tried to be
quiet and fell asleep yeah the nice
thing about tm is that it's bite size
you know like it's really hard to screw
up and i think it was like university
colorado boulder somebody did a study on
it and the only thing that they were
able to prove is that it didn't matter
they asked people after did you think
you had a good session meditation
session or a bad one and there was zero
correlation to whether they thought they
had a good meditation or a bad
meditation to the reduction in cortisol
so it's literally just getting the
cortisol out of your brain
you can't screw it up if you tried yeah
unless you fall asleep i know maybe
that's good
all right listen thank you so much for
uh for joining us uh we definitely have
to get you in here more often now that
uh we're all in miami and uh i think
it's fascinating to hear what uh family
officers are thinking about bitcoin and
kind of how they uh they're starting to
get exposure especially if you know
prices are up or down uh the interest is
still there yeah thanks for having me
appreciate it of course i really enjoyed
talking to eric and i could have talked
to him for way longer seeing his views
on bitcoin in the high inflation
environment and how family offices are
viewing this asset right now in their
portfolio is eye opening also if you're
interested in bitcoin you can go check
out ftx us you can click on the link in
the description ftx will let you buy
bitcoin sometimes as much as 85 cheaper
on transaction fees than their
competitors they continue to innovate in
financial markets and if they're
supporting us i hope that you'll go and
check them out and support them go click
on the link in the description to learn
more and i'll see you all with the next
interview